Okay. So,
welcome back from the break.
Today, I want to talk about an incident
that happened in October 2015 at Yale
University.
What happened was this.
Um Halloween is coming up.
And on Halloween, people like to dress
up silly, get drunk, have a good time.
And a university department called the
Intercultural Affairs Committee sent an
email to students saying, "It's
Halloween. You guys want to have fun.
That's fine, but please be sensitive
about the feelings of other people. So,
for example, do not dress up like a
panda
because we have Chinese students and
they might be offended if you dress up
like a panda." Okay, so this email went
out to all the students at Yale.
And one teacher who works at a
residential residential college called
Silliman. Okay, so Yale, the university,
is divided into dormitories called
residential colleges. And she is a dean
with her husband of this college called
Silliman.
And to her students, she writes an email
and says that she didn't agree with the
university email.
She says that a university is a place
for you to explore, experiment,
and make mistakes.
So,
yes, be sensitive
about the feelings of others,
but we trust you
to make mistakes and to
recover from them. Okay?
So,
um the debate was it's actually over
safe space versus free space. The
university said that safe space is
important. We must respect the feelings
of others.
But the dean of Silliman, her name is
Erika Christakis, she believes in the
idea of
free space.
So, a university is a place for debate,
for questioning, for experimentation.
And yes, feelings will be hurt. That's
part of the
growing up process, the intellectual
process.
So, let me ask you a question.
Do you guys agree with
number one who argues for safe space
or number two, Erika Christakis, who
argues for free space? What do you
think?
Okay. So sorry sorry can can can can can
Can you speak into the mic, please?
Of why don't don't I
>> Yeah. Why do you believe number two is
co-
number one or number two is correct?
Well, because I think that university is
place that you could explore yourself,
you know, jump out of your comfort room
and try the things that you never
had experienced before. Okay. Who
disagrees?
Who believes it's more important to
respect the feelings of others? Um like
if the
the college prohibit these um dressing
that may be a be an offensive to others
students, it's just in the campus. If
you like walk out in the society, it's
still have the people like wants to um
dress with maybe like a panda or
something. So, um
I think it's
I think it's like necessary to like to
um to
Well, I
Uh yeah. Okay. All right.
Any other opinions?
Okay. So, you say respect the rules,
right?
I think I think it depends on who
decided. If it's like for myself, I
think free space will be more important.
I need to explore what I want. But for
being as a leader, being as a head of
the college, I think safe space will be
more important for them cuz they need to
take in control.
Okay. Right, but the problem is this is
a conflict, right?
>> Mhm. If the teachers care about safe
space, you cannot have free space. Mhm.
Right? So, the question then is, what do
you think in principle is more
important, free space or safe space?
Safe space. Okay. Okay.
Okay. All right. Okay. So, yeah, so most
students believe safe space is more
important.
And this marks a generational shift
because when I was growing up,
there was no debate. It was just assumed
that free space is more important
because if you're not allowed to make
mistakes, you're not allowed to explore,
you're not allowed to argue with other
people, if your feelings don't get hurt,
you will never grow as a person.
Okay? So, this marks a generational
divide or generational gap. Okay? So,
um
we're going to look at what happened
because of this debate.
So, the students who read the email were
offended
that Erika Christakis was arguing for
free space because they believed that by
doing this, you're going to hurt our
feelings.
All right? And so, let's look at what
happened.
And remember, this is Yale University.
Okay. So, what's happening is that
when Chris Nicholas Christakis, the
husband of Erika Christakis,
went to a meeting, he was surrounded by
students.
And they're confronting him.
They're confronting him.
They're arguing, okay?
Okay. So,
look, I'm not saying which side is
correct.
Okay? Both sides have legitimate points.
Both sides have problems.
But you will notice that he, the
professor,
he's much older than the students.
And the students are treating him, you
can see their faces, right? They're
treating him with some contempt.
And that's not appropriate.
And when I was growing up, we didn't do
this.
If you didn't like a professor, you
thought,
"Well, he's an asshole." And but you
know what? Most professors are [__]
because they're professors. Okay? You
didn't You did not go and like stalk the
guy
and complain to him. That's kind of
disrespectful.
All right? So, the question then is, why
is this happening? So, I want to show
you another video.
And this video is kind of crazy.
Okay? This video.
Okay. So, this is not appropriate. Okay?
Again, both sides have legitimate
points.
But this is not appropriate, right?
Because what she's saying to him is,
"You work for us. Your job is to make us
feel at home." And his response is, "But
my job is to help you learn.
My job is to help you grow, and that
means openness. That means debate. That
means pain."
And her response is, "I don't want that
crap. I want to feel good. I want to
feel at home. I don't be challenged."
And if you think think about it, that
defeats the entire point of university.
So,
again, I'm not saying who's right.
Um I'm not saying who's wrong,
but clearly there's a problem here.
And when I went to Yale
a long time ago, we didn't have any of
this. In fact, this sort of incident
where a student would curse a professor,
it was unimaginable to us.
Okay?
So, the question then is, why is this
happening?
And
there are three explanations for why
this is happening.
The first explanation is parenting.
These kids grew up in very privileged
household, and their parents are very
protective of them.
And their parents treat them like
friends. And so, these kids are spoiled,
okay? That's the first explanation.
The second explanation is the idea of a
consumerist mentality.
So,
in a university, the idea is that the
students are consumers, they're
customers, and the customers are always
right. What the customers want, you have
to give them.
So, if the customers want a safe space,
they want to come and enjoy their time
at university, and they don't want any
challenge, the professors have to meet
their demands.
Otherwise,
he should not have this job.
Okay? And this is a mentality that we
call neoliberalism
or consumerism.
Okay, that's the second explanation.
Okay? The third explanation is
ideological.
So, the idea is that at universities,
universities are overrun by left-wing
professors who teach students that
society is racist
against minorities
who happen to be, you know, black and
female.
And they must overturn
the white racist supremacist structure.
And you do that by telling white
professors who are privileged
that they are racist.
Okay? So, these are three standard
explanations
for why this is happening. Because this
sort of stuff is happening quite a lot
in America.
What I want to argue to you today
is that there's actually another
explanation, which I think is much more
compelling.
And the explanation is that universities
have become bureaucracies.
Before universities existed to teach you
how to think,
to help professors do cutting-edge
research that helps a society
improve or innovate.
But today, universities, including Yale,
Harvard, all the universities, have
become bureaucracies that exist in order
to promote the interests
of the administrators who want to sit in
their office, get really nice uh get get
a really big salary, and feel good about
themselves. Okay? That's the argument I
will make to you today. And what I will
show you is that this is not just true
for universities, it's true for every
major organization
in America and in the Western world, and
arguably around the world. Okay? That's
the argument I will make to you today.
Any questions before I begin?
All right.
Okay? So, today's lecture is death by
bureaucracy. How the idea of
bureaucracy, the bureaucratic mindset,
is taking over the world.
All right.
So, let's talk about another incident
at Yale. Okay, this is Yale Law School,
and a student named Trevor Coe Berg, he
sends an email. He has a party, he sends
an email
to all the students at Yale Law School.
And there there are actually not that
many students at Yale Law School.
There's maybe 300. Okay? But all the
students get it, and he says that he's
going to organize a party, and it's it's
a trap house party.
And, you know, it's it's a bit of a
joke, because trap house means actually
a drug house, a place where drug dealers
sell
uh drugs.
But black students, African-American
students, read the email, and they're
offended. And they're like, "Are you
making fun of black students?"
So, they write a letter of complaint to
the deans of Yale Law School, and there
are two deans who investigate. Okay,
their names are Eldik and Cosgrove,
okay? And they sit And what Trevor Coe
Berg does is he he actually records the
meeting, okay? Secretly. So, for 20
minutes they talk.
And basically,
Coe Berg does not believe he did
anything wrong. He sent an email,
and he said it it was a funny email. He
thought it was funny, okay? But the
deans tell him, "You think it's funny,
but other students found it offensive.
So, you need to apologize."
And Coe Berg's like,
"Okay. Well, I'll tell you what.
If these students
thought that what I wrote was offensive,
then I will talk to them. We will talk
together about why they found the email
offensive,
and we will settle this amongst
ourselves."
And the deans are like, "No, no, no. We
want to We want to help you guys out. We
want to protect you guys. We're afraid
that you guys meet, you guys will fight
even more."
And Trevor Coe Berg's like, "Well, I
want to hear what they think. I don't
want to hear this from you, I want to
hear what they think, okay? And And then
what happens is that the deans start to
threaten Trevor Coe Berg. They basically
tell him,
"These things apply over time. So, you
must apologize right away
for your sake."
Okay? And they tell him, "Listen, if you
do not apologize,
then this might affect your career. This
might affect your social circle." Okay?
So, they're threatening him.
And
what they say is, "We're doing this for
your sake."
Okay?
Eldik says he worries about the email
affecting students' reputation, not just
here, but when you leave. You know, the
legal community is a small one.
And he says, "You know what?
I will write the email for you.
I will craft the apology for you."
And
Cosgrove warns that escalation is a
possibility if the student doesn't
apologize, okay?
So, this is coercion.
And again, the student It's not clear
what the student did wrong.
Some students found it offensive, but
it's not clear what rules or laws or
what regulations Trevor Coe Berg broke,
okay?
It's not clear.
So, why is this happening? Okay? My
argument to you is that it's happening
because
these guys, Cosgrove and Eldik, they
need things to do. Because being a dean
of a university is not a real job.
Right? There are professors who teach,
there are researchers who do research,
but deans actually don't do anything.
So, when you have a bureaucracy,
bureaucrats go make problems for
everyone in order to create solutions
for everyone.
Okay?
So,
another saying this is,
20 years ago, 30 years ago, when I was a
student at Yale,
if you had a problem,
you had to go talk to a professor.
Because there was no one else to talk
to.
Nowadays, you can talk to like 20 or 30
different deans. Dean of student
affairs, dean of student faculty
relations, who knows, okay? But there
are like all these offices they can go
to. And quite honestly, it's the same at
the school as well, right?
If you don't like me as a teacher,
there's like four or five different
people you can complain complain you can
complain to. And quite honestly, a lot
of you do complain, okay? So, I know
about this. And the And what is
happening is
these universities have become
bureaucracies.
Now, the question then is, why the
bureaucracies? And the answer is,
in the beginning, as a university, you
have to build your reputation, right?
So, you work hard, uh you focus on
teaching, you focus on research.
So, it's a struggle to become a global
brand. Once you become that global
brand, there's nothing else to do.
There's no more ideology, there's no
more struggle. So, what happens is the
people in charge start engaging in
rent-seeking behavior. They take
advantage of the position
in order to make their life easier. And
then they pass on this privilege to
their friends, and then to their
children.
And this creates a bureaucracy.
And the university starts to exist in
order to
empower these people at the expense of
students and professors.
Okay?
All right. So, to show you how
ridiculous this has become,
here's an example.
This is from CNN,
okay? And this is the year 2020.
A University of South California
professor is under fire for using a
Chinese expression students allege
sounds like an English slur, okay? So,
there's a Chinese word that sounds like
an
racial slur, an insult, in English.
These two words actually do not sound
the same.
Okay? You know what the word is, right?
Na ge. Na ge zuo ci, na ge dian nao,
okay? They It's not the same as the
English word, but it sounds a bit
similar. So, what happened was some
black students, African-American
students, who were not in his class,
okay?
Wrote a letter of complaint. And
honestly, if you read it, it sounds like
a joke. It sounds like a prank. All
right, so let's read it together. Let's
Let's Okay, so this is a professor, Greg
Patton, and he's just teaching
communication Chinese. He's just
teaching Chinese to his students on how
to communicate in China when you do
business, okay? And he And he says,
"Look, na ge is just a filler. It
doesn't really mean anything." And he
says it a few times. But there's no
there's no bad intention what he's
saying, right? I mean, he's he's just
pointing out a fact. So,
what these students write is, "This
phrase, clearly and precisely before
instruction, is always identified as a
phonetic homonym and a racially
derogatory term, and should be carefully
used, especially in the context of
speaking Chinese within the social
context of the United States." Okay? So,
this is a ridiculous idea.
And honestly,
it sounds like a joke, okay? It just
sounds like these students are playing a
joke.
And And the prof- And the administration
just ignore this, right? Guess what
happens?
The dean, okay? The head of the business
school
announced that a different professor
would take over teaching Patton's class.
He fired Patton.
And then he said, "Professor Patton
repeated several times a Chinese word
that sounds very similar to a vile
racial slur in English. Understandably,
this caused great pain and upset among
students, and for that I'm deeply sorry.
It is simply unacceptable for faculty to
use words in class that can marginalize,
hurt, and harm the psychological safety
of our students. We must and we will do
better."
Okay?
He's being [__]
It's a joke. It's a prank. And And he's
taking it very seriously.
Why? Because he's trying to protect his
job. He's trying to look good. He's
trying to explain why I'm the leader
because I protect everyone.
Okay?
So, then again, what is Why is this
happening? Well,
I again, the idea of bureaucracy.
So, this is the University of
California, San Diego. This is student
enrollment, okay? So, you can see a
slight increase in student enrollment.
But look at this.
Senior management, deans,
administrators, managers. Boom, okay?
Boom.
This is called rent-seeking behavior.
This is people in power taking advantage
of their power to give jobs to their
friends who do nothing every day.
And because of that, they're always
looking to cause problems for everyone
else, especially professors
who do real work.
Okay? So, let us look at universities.
As you can see, um
the blue is teaching.
So, what's really interesting is that
the
investment in teaching has gone down.
Okay? Sorry. The investment in teaching
has gone down, the blue, okay?
But look at this.
The red is administration.
So,
over the past
from 1980 to today, over the past 40
years, universities have put less money
into both
um administration as well as
maintenance, but have put more money
into administration, into bureaucracy.
Okay? This is where your money's going,
guys. All right? So, this is Illinois.
You see a massive surge in
managers, but at the same time, student
enrollment is going down. It went down
3%.
All right? So, this is a paper written
about the Swedish education system, the
higher education system system, okay?
It's It's no different anywhere else.
All right? So, let's
So, the argument is that bureaucracy is
ballooning in Swedish higher education.
So, let's look at some interesting
statistics.
All right. So, what's happening is that
this chart tells you that teachers
are teaching more and more students.
Okay?
Teachers are teaching more and more
students, but administrators
are managing less and less students.
And the reason why is
teachers are fewer and fewer, but
managers are more and more. That makes
no sense.
Okay?
Um
So, you can see that teachers and
researchers, it's pretty flat, okay? It
hasn't really gone up that much, but
secretaries, people who do real work,
it's going down. But managers are going
up.
Okay? So, if the university is facing
problems, the first thing you should cut
are the people who do no work, right?
But it's the opposite. People who do no
work, the managers, keep their jobs, and
in fact they pay themselves more, and
the professors and the maintenance and
the secretaries lose their jobs to cut
costs.
Okay? Um
This is how much they're paid. As you
can see, over the same time period,
secretaries are getting paid less and
less, teachers are getting paid less and
less, but look at this.
Managers are getting paid more and more.
Uh these are the different departments,
okay?
of a university. So, as you can see,
okay, the the jobs
the departments that do real work, IT,
uh HR, they're going down, but
management is going up.
All right? So, the people who do
actually no work,
their jobs keep on going up and up, and
they get paid more and more.
And as I said, the problem with
bureaucracy is not only do managers do
do nothing every day, but they expect
others to do more work, okay? So,
professors, researchers, teachers,
they're doing more work because
the managers are giving them more
paperwork to do.
Okay? Like evaluations and all that. So,
professors spend all now almost 20% of
their work day on paperwork given to
them by managers.
And this paperwork is not necessary.
It's just given to them to justify the
jobs of the managers, okay?
This is America. We go back to America.
And as you can see, um this is a
university called Gallaudet. And as you
can see, over a 20-year period, these
are blue are the salaries of professors,
and it's pretty stable, okay? You went
from 72 to 86, not a huge increase. But
look, for managers, okay?
The president, it doubled from 141 to
280 to 80.
It doubled. Right now, the salaries are
over three times as much as faculty.
Um
This is Connecticut. At Yale, the
president makes $200,000 a year, and
Wesleyan, he makes $3 million a
year. Okay? Um
This is a private university called
Stratford University. And it went
bankrupt. Right now, more and more
universities are going bankrupt because
obviously you have too many managers,
and all they do is
um get huge paychecks for doing nothing,
eventually you're going to go bankrupt,
right? So, yeah?
I can start Sorry to interrupt, but the
school The school board is not stupid.
So, I mean, this is a fact, and so why
why don't they just change anything?
That's a great question, okay? The
reason why is they're all friends. The
school board, the president, the vice
president, they're all friends.
And that's why they can do this. Because
they can do all the power.
They're all friends. And it's in their
best interest to steal together, right?
Cuz if you steal by yourself, then you
might get caught. But if you steal
together,
then you're untouchable, okay? So, this
is exactly what happens at Stratford
University. The university goes
bankrupt, and because the president and
the vice president are stealing from the
university, stealing because they are
um not only collecting huge paychecks,
but they're also expensing everything to
the university. So, for example, for
example, they buy a car or they have a
gym membership, they charge the
university. And if the university can't
pay for it, what they do is they lend
money to the university.
Okay?
All right? So, Schultz is the president.
He lists himself and his wife as the
biggest creditors, claiming that the
university owed the couple 2.5 million
for eight promissory notes, okay?
So, the university could not pay
uh their cars or their house mortgages,
and they're like And the Schultzes are
like, "Don't worry about it. We'll lend
you the money." And then when the
university went bankrupt, they were
like, "Okay, now you have to pay me
back."
All right? So, So again, how were they
able to do this? Because
The filings also shed light on payments
to university insiders in its final year
of operation. The college paid out of
over 230,000 in payments to seven
trustees. So, the people at the top were
getting paid off
even as the university was going
bankrupt.
Though the filing doesn't differentiate
which expenses were Richard's and which
were Mary Ann's, the filings for 2020
alone showed over 18,000 in lease and
insurance payments for the Schultzes'
cars, okay? So, they had cars, and they
were making the university pay for these
cars.
Over 4.7 million in loan payments and
collateral returned to Eagle Bank on
behalf of the Schultzes, okay? So,
they're also making the university pay
for their houses as well.
And then you're like, "How can they do
this?"
Well, the answer is because in America,
the rich always wins in the court
system. So, whoever is able to hire the
best lawyers always wins out. And they
have a lot of money. The university is
bankrupt. They don't have a lot of
money. So, they will win out.
Okay? So, I point this out because this
is going to What This is what's going to
happen to many universities
over the next 5 10 years in America.
Because you have a system where you have
the managers at the top, they're all
best friends, they're all stealing from
the university together. And eventually
the university will bankrupt.
So,
that's America. Okay? But it's not
Again, it's not just the universities.
It's every bureaucracy. It's every
organization is happening like this. So,
you look at Canada. In Canada, you can
see a rise of that percent in the
population, but look at the government,
okay? It's gone up by 26%.
Um in America,
you can see a stark decline in
manufacturing jobs starting in about the
1980s because these jobs are being
offshored to China. But at the same
time, you can see this
steady increase in government jobs.
Okay?
So, people in America are doing less
real work,
And more and more people are becoming
bureaucrats.
Okay.
So, as you can see
the growth in the government is usually
in management, okay? People who do real
real work, no, it's pretty flat. But,
look at the managers, look at the
administrators, okay? They're going way
up. And it's a pretty steady increase.
All right. So, how do we know the
government doesn't really do anything?
Okay. So, there's a study that shows us
that
um they it's looking at rules, okay? So,
rules help society be more efficient.
So, as you can see
um the number of rules have gone down,
actually. The number of significant
rules, rules that actually impact you
day-to-day, have gone way down. But,
this is interesting, the paperwork has
gone up.
Okay? So, this tells us the managers,
the administrators in the federal
government of of the United States, they
don't do anything but produce paperwork
that's meaningless. That has actually no
impact on the lives of ordinary people.
Okay?
Okay, let's look at the military
military.
So, everyone believes that America has
the world's greatest military
because it spends the most on the
military and has all these high-tech
weapons, right? The problem is the
bureaucracy in the military right now.
So, you see what's happening is an
increase in management because the ratio
of manager officer to soldier is going
down, okay? So, you have more officers
and less soldiers. That's a problem if
you're fighting a war.
All right, so
um
in Civil War, and this is the 1860s, you
had one officer for every 14 soldiers.
Now, it's one to four.
Okay?
The biggest problem is the increase in
generals, okay? So, you can see three-
and four-star generals have increased
the most.
In World War II
um America had about 12 million
soldiers. They had seven generals who
are four-star.
Today, America has about 1.2 million
soldiers. They have 40
four-star generals.
And this is a huge problem. Why? Because
if you're a four-star general
you have a lot of privileges beyond your
salary.
So, uh this is from Raymond Dubois, who
works in the Pentagon, and he writes
about the perks of a four-star general.
A four-star has an airplane. A
three-star often doesn't. Can a
three-star get an airplane when he needs
it? Not always. Okay? So, a four-star
general always has his own personal
airplane. What is his personal airplane?
It's called a G5. This is what a G5 is,
guys.
This is what a G5 is.
This is his own personal plane.
It's always there for him.
If he If he doesn't want to fly, it's
waiting on the tarmac for him, okay? You
can see how luxurious it is. This costs
50 to 60 million dollars per plane.
Every four-star general has this plane.
At the same time, guys, what's happening
to soldiers?
The soldiers
don't have enough to eat.
There's 1.2 million veterans on food
stamps.
Okay, that's 8% of all veterans in
America. The people who actually
fight, the people who actually make
sacrifices for their country, don't have
enough to eat while the generals fly
around in like these really nice planes.
That's the state of the American
military.
All right, so it's not just military,
it's every single
US government department, okay? All the
administrator
you see massive increase in
administration.
All right, so people who do real work,
it's in the red. People who do actually
no work, it's in the blue, okay? So,
people who do science, math,
engineering, 621. People who do
administration, 782.
So, in every federal bureaucracy, you
have bloat.
You have managers who do nothing, and
you have very few people people who do
the actual real work. It's It's It's
true for every single federal
organization in in America.
So, this just shows you how the ratio of
managers is compared to other employees.
What's really funny about bureaucracy is
evaluation is very important. Who does
the evaluation? Managers do the
evaluation.
So, at the end of the year, they do do
they do performance review, and what
happens is they tell they evaluate
themselves and their friends and say,
"We did a great job." And then look at
other people who do the real work and
says, "You guys could do better, okay?"
So, outstanding is the highest
uh performance review for the
government, right? 62%
got outstanding, okay? Managers who do
nothing every day.
47%
got outstanding
for every other job.
All right? So, it's a rigged game.
Same Same thing with hospitals.
The The brown is the growth in
doctors. You can see it's pretty steady.
But, look at the administrators.
Okay? The yellow are the administrators.
It It's blowing up, okay?
And so, it caught It forces health care
costs to go up.
The reason why health care is so
unaffordable in the United States is not
because it has the best health care in
the world. It doesn't. It's so It's
expensive because it's got so many
administrators who do nothing every day.
All right? So,
what do they What do these managers do?
Well, the managers always think of new
ways to screw everyone else.
Okay, so these are
health insurance companies.
And this is their denial rates, okay?
So, you work hard for 40 years, you pay
your health insurance, okay? And then
maybe you get cancer. And then you go to
a doctor, the doctor charges you like a
million dollars. And you're like, you
don't have a million dollars, but you
have insurance, so you go to the
insurance company. It's like, "Hey, I
paid 40 years of insurance fees.
Can you help me out?" And then And look,
the insurance company you don't have
health care
about a third
32% of all claims are denied.
And they do this as practice
because
if you fight them, they'll say, "Okay,
you know what? We'll We'll We'll We'll
agree to pay you back, okay?"
But, if you don't fight them, then
they're like, "Great."
Okay? So, it's extremely unethical. And
so, that's what what managers do every
day. Think of new ways to screw over
their patients
and doctors.
All right.
So, why is this happening?
All right? Why is America like this? Why
is the West like this? Why Why is the
entire world like this?
So, this is Franz Kafka.
And he was writing
before World War I. This is his most
famous book called The Trial.
Okay, I'm not sure if you guys have read
this book or heard of heard of this
book, okay? It's very good.
And the novel, it's a very interesting
novel because the main character, Joseph
K.
He works at a bank. He's a black bank
clerk. And he has never gotten any
into trouble his entire life, okay? He's
very obedient, he's very nice, he just
sticks to himself.
And then one day, the police come and
arrest him.
The police don't tell him why.
And
Joseph K. tries to figure out why, but
he He does not know what he did wrong.
He does not know why he's being
arrested.
And then he's put on trial. And the
judge doesn't tell him what he did
wrong.
Okay? And Joseph K. is trying to figure
out why is this happening to me, okay?
And this And And And this is his answer.
"Its purpose is to arrest innocent
people and wage
pointless prosecutions against them,
which, as in my case, lead to no result.
How are we to avoid those in office
becoming deeply corrupt when everything
is devoid of meaning?" Okay? Because
society has become a bureaucracy, and
bureaucrats need things to do.
So, they go the police go and arrest
innocent people
and then
send them to
trial, okay?
Now, what he doesn't say is
the police could arrest criminals,
right? But, the police don't want to do
that because the criminals might fight
back.
Or the criminals might
uh
be mean, okay?
They'd rather arrest an innocent person
because they know the person will be
compliant.
Okay, that's the logic of bureaucrats.
How do I
justify my existence by doing as little
work as possible?
Okay?
So,
this sounds strange, but let me tell you
a story. This is a true story.
I'm in Toronto
with my two boys
and I let them run around the park,
okay?
And we've been doing this for two
months.
So, I trust them.
One of my boys, he's 4 years old he went
too far. And I lose track of him, okay?
A stranger finds him and starts talking
to him. But, my boy doesn't speak any
English.
So,
people now surround my boy, like, "Where
Where's Where your parents?"
And he is scared.
Because he doesn't speak any English.
So, he faints, okay? That That's what he
does. He faints to protect himself. So,
they call the police, they call the the
paramedics. They come, and make sure
he's all right, okay? Now I find him.
Okay? And now the police
interview me, they interrogate me, and I
explain to him what happened.
And at this point, they just let us go
home, right? But they insist on taking
us to the hospital.
I'm like,
"If we go to hospital, we could be stuck
there for like 12 hours. We we we could
be in line and like the paramedics, the
EMTs had already told us there's nothing
wrong with him."
Okay? It's not a heat stroke, he just
fainted. But he's fine. His vital signs
are fine. But the police kept kept on
insisting. Meanwhile, there's a fight
going on at the park, okay? And I'm
thinking to myself, "Why are you guys
bothering me
and not going to arrest those guys who
are fighting
somewhere else?" And the answer is
because it's easier to deal with me than
it is to go arrest those guys, okay?
That's how bureaucrats think.
They're always thinking of ways to
justify their existence,
but not do real work.
Okay? And that's the
message of the trial. Eventually,
society becomes so bureaucratic
that the bureaucrats only think about
how to make problems for ordinary
citizens
because life becomes easier for them.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
All right.
Let's move on to
the origins of totalitarianism by Hannah
Arendt. Hannah Arendt is a 20th
century's one of the 20th century's most
uh powerful intellectuals.
And she's writing about how Nazism came
to dominate Germany, how communism came
to dominate Soviet Russia.
And how these two regimes
led to the deaths of tens of millions of
people.
How they started World War II, how
they created the Holocaust, how they
created the famine, okay?
And in her book, she she says that these
two regimes are religious cults. They're
evil cults.
And they have three defining
characteristics.
Okay? The first is that they are removed
from reality. They don't care about
reality. They have a religion, they have
a faith, they have a mindset, and they
want to impose
their faith on reality, okay? They don't
care about reality. They're removed from
reality.
That's the first thing, okay?
Second thing is that when you're removed
from reality, the your only logic is
movement, expansion.
Okay? You only know if you're right if
you're growing.
Okay? So, if the Nazis, their faith,
their religion would lead to the
destruction of Germany, but their
membership was increasing, so they were
right.
They were winning these wars against
European countries, therefore they're
right.
Okay? They cannot use logic
to explain their actions, so they use
movement to
to justify their actions, okay? That's
number two.
One and two means number three, which is
the Nazis and the Soviets
hated reality. They defied reality. They
fought against reality. So, even though
the Nazis were losing the war, even
though it's clear they could not defeat
the Soviet Russia, they doubled down.
Because in their religion,
movement is what matters. Defying
reality is what matters. And that's what
led to the destruction of Germany.
Okay?
All right. So, and she explains that
totalitarian regimes have these three
characteristics. They are removed from
reality. All they care about is
expansionism, and they want to defy
reality
as their true test of faith.
What she does not say in the book
is that these three can can be applied
to all bureaucracies,
all governments, meaning that over time,
all governments, all bureaucracies will
tend towards totalitarianism.
Because they have That's the only way
they can justify their existence.
Okay? Does that make sense? All right.
So, let's let's talk about this
concretely, okay? What do I mean by
this?
So, this is a book by James Scott. It's
an excellent book, by the way. Uh called
Seeing Like a State. And he's trying to
explain to us how bureaucracies
bureaucracies work, how governments
function.
And for him,
governments actually create more
problems than they solve.
Why?
Well, he lists four reasons.
The first is that he
All they care about is the
administrative ordering of nature and
society. So So, another way of saying
this is
a bureaucracy is a machine. It's a
hierarchy. It's static. It's mechanical.
But society is like a forest. It's
diverse.
It's an ecosystem. It's organic.
For a state to exist, it must turn the
forest into
a machine like itself.
So, it destroys diversity. It destroys
spontaneity. Spontaneity. It destroys
imagination, okay?
All right. So, let let's
use an example of this, all right? So,
my question to you is like, who are you?
Can Can you Can you tell us who who are
you? Like Like who are you as a person?
Tell us who you are as a person.
Yeah. Yeah. Just Just use 1 or 2 minutes
just to to introduce yourself. Who are
you as a person? Hi, my name is Banker,
and I I grew up in Beijing. Uh
and I came to
Moonshot, this this school
in 2024
last year, and uh Okay, wrong. Wrong,
okay? That's That's not the correct
answer. The right answer is you're a
teenage boy.
Oh. Okay? That's the correct answer.
All right? You believe that you are an
individual with individual aspirations,
ambitions, with a past, with a history.
The state doesn't care. The state needs
to classify you in a way that can that I
can use you, okay? You're a teenage boy,
which means like 2 years time you can be
employed in a factory, or I can send you
to war.
Okay? That's all I care about. Okay? I
don't care about your name, I don't care
about who you are, I don't care who your
parents are, I don't care about your
past, I don't care what you like. All I
care about is the fact that you are a
teenage boy, and therefore I can I can
exploit you for labor.
Okay? That's how states think.
Okay? So,
the bureaucratization of society. Second
is the idea of high modernist ideology.
So, because the state is a monopoly, the
bureaucracy is a monopoly, it becomes
arrogant. It has hubris. It's
overconfident. And it it wants to impose
its ideology on everyone else.
It believes that through its own
planning, it can achieve paradise.
Okay?
Um so, it becomes authoritarian, meaning
it refuses to listen to criticism, to
feedback,
to questions.
It does It is not open to debate.
It It imposes its will on people.
Okay? Which creates a weak civil
society.
And if if as an organization you're not
getting feedback,
you're not allowing for openness, then
you will wither and die.
Okay? And that's why states, governments
will always fail in the end.
Okay. So, he uses two examples.
The first example is what happened in
the late uh 19th century Germany.
So, in Germany there's there's lots of
forest.
And the state is thinking of ways, how
can we how can we best
monetize the resource of the forest?
Well, there's certain trees that you can
cut down for lumber, right? The problem
is that in a forest, most space is
occupied by useless
shrubs or greenery or trees. Okay? So,
their brilliant idea is, "You know what?
Here's a simple solution.
We'll burn down the forest and just
plant trees that we can harvest for
lumber."
Right?
Brilliant. That's a brilliant use of
space.
It's more efficient.
The problem though is that when you do
that,
the trees are now are susceptible to
disease,
to weather changes. A forest is
resilient because it's diverse.
Okay? So, that's what This is what Scott
Scott says.
Monocultures are as a rule more fragile
and hence more vulnerable to the stress
of disease and weather than polycultures
are. Any unmanaged forest may experience
stress from storms, disease, drought,
fragile soil, or severe cold. A diverse,
complex forest, however, with its many
species of trees, its full complement of
birds, insects, and mammals is far more
resilient, far more able to withstand
and recover from such injuries than pure
stands.
So, nature has diversity because it
allows for resilience.
Okay? Some part of the forest can die,
but the rest of the forest will recover
from anything, whether it's disease or
drought or weather, okay? And we humans
are the same way.
If you let humans do what they want,
we are resilient. So, some communities
might die off, but other communities
will adapt.
The problem with the state
with the government is that
it refuses
it sees diversity as an enemy.
Okay? So, if there's a natural disaster,
it's very likely that a lot more people
die off than
otherwise, okay?
Another example is
forced communism in Tanzania.
Okay? So, it's a top-down system. And
their idea is, "Okay, these farmers have
their little small farms, and they grow
their crops, but that's not efficient.
What if we just got all the farmers
together and had coffee?"
And they all, you know, had coffee
uh
or weed or whatever. And then we can
sell this to other countries.
Okay? And of course, you can imagine
that this will lead to starvation.
Because it's the same principle as the
forest. If there's a weather crisis, or
if there's a disease, then all your
crops die off, and then your people die
off. Okay?
What these planners carried in their
mind's eye was certain aesthetic, what
one might call a visual quantification
of modern world production and communi-
community life, okay? So, the problem
with bureaucrats is they have no
imagination. Everything has to them has
to be mapped out. They like things that
can be mapped out, that that can be a
blueprint, okay? They like to brag about
these things, because because that's how
they see the world.
But real world
nature requires diversity, it requires
organic.
Okay?
All right. So, he gives examples of how
the state transforms society. So, before
what happened is that people would just
come together and they would organize
their communities according to their
needs.
Okay, it's a bottom-up process, but the
state wants to create permanent cities
where people are just in one place all
the time.
Right?
That's why you have
cities.
Um
before, what's natural is just for
people to live on small farms and share
stuff with other people, to trade with
with each other. The problem with this
is the state cannot tax you.
So, what the state does is it brings you
to cities, makes you work in a factory
so I can tax you. Okay? The point of
giving you a wage is so I can tax you,
to exploit you.
Um property
um before, it was very common for people
to share
property together, okay?
Now, there's
it's all owned and controlled by the
state.
Uh resources are the same thing. Before,
people just used resources according to
their needs.
But now the state wants to centralize
these resources.
Okay, so it can tax and exploit people
properly.
Okay? So, that's what a state proxy
does. So, what are the consequences of
the over-bureaucratizing of society?
Well, what's happening in America is
that while consumer goods like cars,
clothing, and cell phones are going
down, what's going up are hospital
services,
schooling, okay? Housing. Why? Because
these are monopolies controlled by
bureaucrats.
Right? So, what's happening is with the
over-bureaucratizing of society, it's
almost impossible for middle-class
people, ordinary people, to have a good
life now.
Here's another really interesting chart.
The black shows you the growth in the
stock market, okay?
And you think you think, "Wow, this is a
good thing."
Okay? The problem
is, first of all, only 10% of people in
the United States control most of the
stocks, not over 90% of the stocks. The
other issue is this. The other issue is
if you look at prices, yeah, it's going
up. But if you just turn but if you look
at stocks
as
uh units of gold, if you use gold to buy
stocks, guess what? The price of stocks
have gone down. That's the blue, okay?
If you use money to buy stocks, it goes
up. But if you use gold to buy stocks,
it goes down. What is this telling us,
okay? Very simple is
we are living in a lie.
All this wealth generation, it's all a
lie. It's not real.
We just think it's real. We we're living
in a fairyland created by bureaucrats to
fool us to believe that we are
prosperous.
Okay, does that make sense?
The amount of gold that you can buy with
stocks has gone down.
Okay?
Okay, so the blue is the gold, the black
is money. The money isn't is worthless.
Okay?
All right. Another problem that
bureaucratization has created is people
don't want to work anymore.
So, in America, this is called quiet
quitting. In China, it's called tang
ping or bai lan, okay? Lying flat, let
it rot. People don't want to work
anymore. Why? Because it's pointless to
work
in a bureaucracy, right?
Leaders don't care.
Bureaucracy doesn't need you.
You are alienated.
You are told what to do, and you cannot
negotiate.
You cannot rise within the bureaucracy.
You're you're being asked to work too
too much.
You feel as though you're just a
machine.
Okay? And so, you're And so, the way you
rebel is
lying flat. Okay, or quiet quitting,
okay? So, your over-bureaucratization of
society means that people now have
become more lazy, more complacent, more
more indifferent.
And what this also means is that
democracy is declining, because people's
voice, people people's power is
declining, okay? So, you can see that
people feel as though democracy is in
the decline. In fact, experts
um
estimate that democracy, the capacity
for people to participate in politics,
the capacity for people to influence
politics, has declined rapidly these
past
10 years, okay?
So, we are living in a world that is
becoming more and more bureaucratic, and
it's killing us.
Okay?
All right.
Questions?
So, as you say, we now live in a very
corrupt world.
We live in a bureaucratic world. Yeah,
very corrupt world. So, what
So, I I I I I can't really see the
future of
no matter it's
the mankind or like are there any good
side of the current world?
Okay.
What What are What are good things about
the current world?
Well, the good
um side is that because things have
become so corrupt,
people now are forced to think for
themselves.
Right? Before, you could just trust your
teacher. You could just trust your
parent. You could just trust author-
authority figures. But now you see them
for the bureaucrats that they are. And
so, now you're forced to think for
forced to think for yourself. And so,
you're now forced to educate yourself.
You're now forced to explore different
opinions. So, people's minds are
opening, and that I think is a very good
thing in today's world.
Okay?
Any more questions?
So, would it help if we canceled
uh
most of the managers and just I keep one
one or two of them?
Like
Yeah, okay. So, that's a really good
question, okay? If this is a problem,
why not just get rid of the managers?
And the answer is they have all the
power.
Okay? They would much rather send you to
war
and kill you off
than to than to lose their jobs.
Okay? So, go back go back example of
Stanford University. This That Their
mentality is, "How do I maintain my
privilege?" They don't care about
society. All they care about is
maintaining their privilege.
Right? So, they are bankrupt society,
and then when society becomes bankrupt,
they expect society to still continue to
pay them off.
Okay? So, these are parasites, and
there's nothing we can do about it. Yeah
Yeah?
Um as we just said, are there less
teacher and less professor or like let
like most of people would choose to
quiet quitting, then who are they going
to control
if there's less people to work for them?
You know,
Okay.
That's a really
good question.
The problem is they don't think like
that. They don't think about "How
efficient is my organization?" They
don't think about like "Am I going to
have a job next 5 years?" All they care
about is maintaining their position
right here and now.
Okay? And the way they do that is they
hire their friends, or people like them,
into other man- and man- management
positions. So, they become like a cabal,
or a or a
network onto themselves.
And for them, they they become
parasites.
And what parasites want to do is they
want to feed off the host. When the host
dies, what's going to happen? They will
switch to another host.
Right? Why? Because they're all part of
larger networks as well. So, that's how
they think. They're thinking, "Well, you
know, as long as society survives, I
will continue to have a job." Okay? So,
maybe this university goes bankrupt, but
there's another university I can go to
and exploit. And And you know what? It
works.
Okay?
Because people at the top protect each
other.
Right?
Okay, does that make sense? They don't
care about this hole this hole They
don't care about this organization. They
don't care if it They don't care if it
goes bankrupt, because they can always
move on to another organization to
bankrupt.
Okay? what matters is to maintain their
patronage, the political networks. So,
they all help each other.
That doesn't make sense? Okay, great.
Any more questions?
Um is there any possible to stop or even
reverse this
cooperating system?
Yeah, um I keep on explaining this this
this this, okay? They are the ones in
power. And so, what has to happen is
also society has to society has to
collapse
before society can regenerate before
society can rejuvenate. Okay? But,
before society can collapse they have a
lot of tricks up their sleeves, okay?
So, for example, they can create civil
wars where the left and the right fight
each other and they're left alone. Or,
they can use AI to control you, right?
AI is God, guys. Listen to God.
Okay? Or, they can fake an alien
invasion.
Okay? Or, they can send you to war. They
send you all these pointless wars. Okay?
But, whatever it takes in order to
maintain their privilege and their
power, that's the mentality. And that's
how they got to where they are.
Okay? And that's how the elite think.
Any more questions, guys?
Okay, Mr. Dow. My question is
so, I'm a 12th grader. So, if you are in
my shoe, like if you are in a 12th
grader in nowadays, what would you do?
Like, are you still going to pursue for
a further education, higher education,
or were you going to like just drop out?
Yeah. Okay. That is a great question.
So, you are you guys are about to to go
to university. And as I told you in this
class, university is a complete rip-off,
okay? All you're doing is you're paying
for the nice salaries and perks of these
administrators at university. You're not
really paying for the professors.
All right? You're paying for the
administrators to have their nice lives.
And so, what I would do is maybe not go
to university. What I would do is focus
on education, on learning by reading a
lot of books, by um asking a lot of
questions and doing my own research, by
learning real skills.
Okay? So, in a society like this where
the game is rigged,
going to university means that you'll
just lose.
Okay? Maybe before like 20, 30 years
ago, it was good to go it was good to go
to university because you might become a
manager.
But, now all those slots
have been taking taking up by the elite
and their children. Okay? There's no
space for you.
So, the only thing you can do in this
context is to really start educating
yourself in real knowledge.
All right? Reading books,
um
meeting lots of different people,
exploring the world, okay? Like, really
develop real knowledge.
Okay? That's that's the best solution.
All right? Any more questions?
Does it matter to the major?
>> No, it does not matter the major. It's
all a scam. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Okay? It's all a scam. Even for
liberals?
Uh
it's all a scam, okay? Doesn't matter
what university you go to, liberal arts,
Ivy League, state, it's all a scam.
Doesn't matter what your major is,
economics, psychology, humanities,
computer science, it's all a scam, okay?
This system exists so that the managers,
administrators can continue to feed off
the system.
All right?
Okay, guys. So, uh we'll continue this
next week, okay? All right.
But, thank you for the questions.